was mich beschäftigt ich würde gar nicht
sagen empörts und wirklich was mich
bewegt und was mich beschäftigt und das
ist jetzt denken Sie es wird dröge würde
es aber nicht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und zwar
beschäftigt mich dass der
Befangenheitsantrag gegen den
bundesverfassungsgerichtspräsidenten
Stefan habert abgelehnt wurde wenn ich
frage mich schon seit längerem macht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht seinen Job noch
richtig schützt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht wirklich unsere
Verfassung ich weiß es sind harte fragen
wie komme ich dazu mich das überhaupt zu
Fragen der Grund liegt darin ein Corona
vor allem eigentlich ja in der
corona-pandemie seine Urteile lassen
mich nämlich Zweifel aufkommen ich
möchte Ihnen gern zwei Beispiele nennen
das Gesetz zum Schutz der Bevölkerung
bei einer epidemischen Lage nationaler
Tragweite hatte weitreichende
freiheitseinschränkungen für uns alle
zufolge es kam auch klagen es kam
Eilanträge es kamen
Verfassungsbeschwerden aber die wurden
alle aus formellen Gründen abgelehnt und
das zweite Beispiel Beispiel weswegen
ich mich manchmal Frage ob das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gerade noch
seinen Job richtig macht war auch die
Ausgangssperre es kam klagen bis heute
ist kein Urteil gefällt worden über die
Ausgangssperren wir müssen doch vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht erwarten können
das sind so einem Fall direkt
entschieden wird nach meinem langen
Monolog will ich die Runde aber jetzt
auch gerne öffnen wie meine Gäste hier
das heute Abend sehen ob die
Verfassungsrichter noch ihren Job
richtig machen ich glaube nein wir sehen
dass die Unabhängigkeit von der Politik
die geben nicht mehr gegeben ist wir
sehen die Verfassungsrichter sind eher
klaköre der Politik geworden das hat
schon begonnen mit der EZB Politik mit
den Urteilen zum Euro zum Beispiel und
seit Jahren muss man tatsächlich sich
fragen warum werden Politiker ernannt
von der Politik die dann auch noch ein
Parteibuch haben das finde ich ist ein
großes Manko im ganzen System die
Unabhängigkeit ist nicht mehr gewährt
und damit ist auch zu Demokratie
gefährdet
sie sprechen ja jetzt hier an das
Professor Dr habert das ist ja der
bundesgerichtspräsident der war bis 2018
Abgeordneter der CDU-Fraktion im
Bundestag wurde von dort Vize und wenig
später Präsident des
Verfassungsgerichtes und es gab ja dann
auch noch ein Abendessen mit der
Kanzlerin darüber hat die Welt auch zum
Beispiel berichtet aber woher kommt das
mit dem bundesverfassungsrecht also wie
könnte man es machen jeder hat ja
eigentlich eine politische Couleur
sollte derjenige nicht vorher tätig
gewesen sein oder
basisdemokratisch entscheiden Wert des
oberste Gerichts Amt erhält eine
basisdemokratische Entscheidung so wie
die Bundestagswahl auch abgestimmt haben
könnten wir auch die die Richter die
über jawohl und Leute sozusagen
entscheiden bestimmen und das wird auch
mal eine gute Idee statt irgendwelche
Politiker das irgendwelche Politiker
einfach entscheiden wer jetzt da mit
welchen Parteibuch hervorkommen dann
muss sie einhalten fand ich alles genau
kann nicht nur zustimmen aber die Bürger
denn der der normale Durchschnittsbürger
der kennt doch Persönlichkeiten gar
nicht wie soll die werden entscheiden
wer gut ist und wer nicht so gut ist
also das halte ich für wir könnten doch
auch in Herrn Scholz nicht vorher ein
Laschet oder Frau Bernburg dieser
Politiker laufend im Fernsehen der
yorkshows und so aber diese diese
Richter die kennt doch kaum jemand also
da also in dem Punkt würde ich eher
vorsichtig sein ansonsten Herr Friedrich
bin ich bei ihnen aber in dem Punkt
würde ich vorsichtig aber ich glaube
entschuldigung aber was was mich
tatsächlich wahnsinnig bewegt ist das
hier ein ganz großer Fehler begangen
wurde das ist nämlich dieses brisante
Abendessen tatsächlich gab weil das
zeigt ja dass im Endeffekt die Regierung
damit auch die das gesamte System
Karlsruhe in dem blöde Situation
gebracht hat ich meine es ist ein
hochsensibles Thema und gerade in dem
Moment wo wir riskieren eine
Vertrauenskrise in den Staat und in
unsere Rechtsstaatlichkeit auszulösen
ist glaube ich etwas passiert was fatal
ist denn diese Vertrauenskrise haben wir
zu teilen eh schon im Moment und ich
glaube es liegt gerade jetzt auch eine
große Chance in der neuen Regierung zu
sagen wir können es schaffen wieder
Vertrauen in Politik und auch in unseren
Rechtsstaat wieder herzustellen also ich
glaube auch dass in dieser ganzen causa
dieses Abendessen eine wichtige Rolle
spielt weil dieses Abendessen die Nähe
im sprichwörtlichen Sinne im
ausdrücklichen Sinne die Nähe zwischen
zwei
fassungsorganen nicht
zu ausgeprägt sein lässt ich bin nicht
ganz bei dir bei Ihnen dass daraus
automatisch folgt weil jetzt der
verfassungsgerichtspräsident oder
Verfassungsrichter mit der
Bundeskanzlerin zu einem
Gedankenaustausch zusammengekommen
urteilen die nur noch urteilen die nur
noch urteilen die nur noch so wie es der
Kanzlerin passt ich glaube als das deckt
sich nicht mit meinem Eindruck von der
Persönlichkeitsstruktur von hohen
Richtern die schon eine sagen wir mal
extrem wenn man sagt egoistische uns
selbst
verherrlichendet dann ist man manchmal
noch ganz charmant also die haben schon
eine gute Meinung von sich und ich
glaube auch die Meinung es ist uns doch
egal wer neben oder über uns
Bundeskanzlerin ist über uns gibt
sowieso keine Kanzlerin sondern wir sind
die letzte Instanz den Weg würde ich
nicht mitgehen die Auffälligkeiten in
dem genannten Fall müssen uns aber
sozusagen sensibel dafür machen dass wir
nicht wirklich auf die von ihnen
vorgetragene Idee kommen dass das die
Demokratie gefährdet ich finde auch mit
der Formulierung die finde ich als
Mahnung richtig aber ich würde im
gegenakzent setzen das ist schon
geschehen ist also ich glaube nicht dass
die Demokratie dadurch schon gefährdet
ist die Pandemie mit all ihren
kollateralleffekten hat aber dazu
beigetragen dass es geschehen könnte und
das konnte ich mir vor der Pandemie
nicht vorstellen das ist das was mir
sorgen macht und da ist es ein wichtiger
Aspekt
ja ich würde auch tatsächlich sagen dass
wir jetzt im letzten Jahren gesehen
haben vor allem wird die
corona-maßnahmen das ist Vertrauen in
die Institution immer weiter abgenommen
hat das erodiert praktisch und es gab
verfassungssprüche muss man ganz klar
sagen also die Ausgangssperre zum
Beispiel in Bayern die waren nicht recht
und es ist bis jetzt ja obwohl die
Klagen liegen seit April vor ich finde
mit den ausgangsspannen ist auch das
wichtigste Moment liegen seit April war
die Geschwindigkeit von Gerichtsurteilen
insbesondere von höchsten Gerichten ist
ja eine viel diskutierte immer wieder
diskutierte Sache sie kommen
logischerweise immer zu spät weil es ja
eben nicht so ist dass ein Gesetz vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht erst
freigegeben werden muss sondern es
urteilt danach sozusagen und die
Zeitspanne und das ist eigentlich der
Kritikpunkt ich bin nicht sicher ob man
es an dem Mann festmachen kann und an
einem sagen wir mal befangenheitsvorwurf
aber was man aber auf jeden Fall sagen
kann ist dass wenn in der Pandemie
Geschwindigkeit gefordert ist dann ist
sie auch bei urteilen gefordert ich kann
nur sagen wenn während der gesamten
Pandemie ist nicht möglich war bis
Montag die korrekten Zahlen vorliegen
weil die Gesundheitsämter am Wochenende
nicht arbeiten dann ist es fast zu viel
verlangt vom Verfassungsgericht
schneller zu sein
aber wir müssen natürlich aufpassen dass
wir tatsächlich auch nicht eine Krise
komplett herbeirreden auf Grundlage
eines einzigen Abendessens wir haben
irgendwie eine Gewaltenteilung ich finde
wir haben ein Rechtsstaat der
vorbildlich agiert der auch in vielen
Fällen und ich würde mal sagen nicht nur
in der Mehrheit sondern fast allen
Fällen vernünftig agiert und gerade
dieses Vertrauen in die
Verfassungsgericht und generell in
unsere Richterinnen und Richter sollten
wir jetzt nicht fort schnell verurteilen
und das ist sonst eine ganz gefährliche
wir sollten auch in einem fair sein wenn
wir heute unsere
Todeszahlen unsere Infektionsraten sehen
dann sind wir deutlich besser ich glaube
als die meisten Länder auf der Welt es
gibt ja Länder wie Russland die haben
momentan 30 40.000
neue jeden Tag also die Politik hat ja
nicht insgesamt schlecht gearbeitet dass
das sehe ich zumindest so weil die
objektiven Fälle die wir haben an an
Menschen die die gestorben sind sind bei
doch deutlich niedriger niedriger als in
den meisten anderen Ländern also deshalb
nicht jetzt pauschale Kritik in dem
Punkt ja Frau Schink ich kann da nicht
widersprechen das sieht schon das sieht
schon etwas merkwürdig ein Einzelfall
also das ist kein Einzelfall wir haben
auch andere Politiker den Parteibuch
haben die auch dann nach oben kommen und
Fakt ist tatsächlich die
verfassungsbrücke sind wir teilweise
schon länger gegen die
maastrichterverträge z.B die ganzen die
ganzen Urteile zu EZB Politik sind
eigentlich ein Skandal und warum haben
wir dieses diesen maastrichtervertrag
abgeschlossen wenn sich kein Land
innerhalb der EU dabei wenn man ist ja
zurückgetreten ich glaube das gar nicht
mehr wobei muss er muss er kann nicht
sagen was er wirklich denkt den Eindruck
habe frei ich finde aber auch wichtig
ist ich habe das ja auch nicht so
verstanden von Nena als eine quasi
pauschale Justiz stellte sondern als ein
als eine Frage als ein Achtung und ich
finde es schimmert eine sehr
interessante Frage durch nämlich wer
kontrolliert eigentlich den Kontrolleur
genau also wie das Oberste Gericht hat
ja nur den Luxus anders als alle anderen
das sind außer von der Öffentlichkeit
also uns unsere Runde zum Beispiel gar
nicht kontrolliert wird sondern das ist
endgültig wann gibt es eigentlich schon
mal in unserer Systematik und deshalb
ist es wirklich wichtig dass man alle
Fragezeichen die aufkommen groß an die
Wand malt und darüber diskutiert und
wenn wenn das flächendeckend gemacht
wird dann ist der oberste Kontrolleur
kontrolliert aber nur dann kann
[Musik]